rebound handle
[Applause]
[Music]
Nader knows clock is down don't stop
been given a turbine recovery the denial
time Clark covered up by Porter five to
shoot Moran works against prey on the
baseline
still with it
[Applause]
let me just say something amazing
how did he even have the space to get
the shot off so the Warriors want to
take every chance that you get to
evaluate
got the triple
is dead-on smarter judge hmm
start and finish here to the second
floor Solomon Hill off the pump fake I
ran with a pump fake oho better hit down
Oh whoopsie uh-oh whoa whoops whoops
where'd he go where'd he go let me
compose myself hey then knock you down
here to come up with it you had to
compose himself earth because after you
make the movies like okay that did
happen
so it really cost you missed two free
throws and they get a dunk at the other
end
it'll be zion those who soft hands cuz
the pass wasn't exactly on target about
we'll take it you know the confidence
you have in the guard to know the
Hawkins throw it up there anywhere and
he'll come down with it that ball hit
off the glass
Green misses a floater there's now with
a pickup grizzlies a chance for the lead
[Applause]
Wow I ran to the basket it seemed like
he could head one more step
please don't leave those that I got the
flip in my game as he rolled one in
sometimes there's no word for partner
you only got a sound for hey go behind
your back
split the fake the defender takeaway
finish this off off the glass of some
dust no words it's just me yeah almost
stolen by George Magoffin
say you you better get back on D Alonso
fine what great court vision and then to
make the pass right on target that's
what's underrated but that is not SIA
makes it look easy rebound the ranch
you think that you have to
but he even thinks that he is in the
most control of the basketball and that
once he gets that control
well the C's part that lettuce isms
xover the highlight finish reduced Moran
with a running start with elevation oh
my word what I didn't clear it out last
time where they cleared it out this time
come get some Aron Baynes what up at you
boy Adam left coach you like that
content I know you like that content hit
subscribe for more of it from Bleacher
Report